and we have to remember and you touched
upon it you know business is an infinite
game
and I love it when companies say you
know we're number one I'm like well
first of all you don't even know who
your competitors are you know second of
all a new competitor can join the game
at any time
um oh and by the way even if you and
companies will say no Simon we really
are number one and I'll say for now
for now you know and and this is what I
love about the internet game you just
add for now at the end of a com any
accomplishment you're like oh my God
this is the worst year we've ever had
for now you know like this is we aren't
we are the best for now
and you can never get cocky but you can
never believe that the bottom is is the
bottom either because it's it's an
infinite game and I think any company
that strives to be the best
well you're picking your own metrics I
mean you can be the best at anything but
to be better every single day is a much
better thing to strive for in an
infinite game